If we talk about snake, then it produces two types
of toxins, hemo
toxin and neuro toxin. These are the
most deadly toxins. What do they
do? If you talk about hemo toxin,
then it goes into our blood stream and destroys
RBCs.  What will they do? They will contract you, they will die,
due to which our heart will
not get proper blood supply and the heart will
stop working. If we talk about neuro toxin, then
neuro toxin affects our central
nervous system and it
What will it do? It will
stop giving signals to our neurons. So
what will happen in both the cases. If a person is
bitten by a snake, then what do we have to give?
Anti-venom injection has to be given so that
we can save the life of that person.